June was God's key is about to undergo a
simple procedure to relieve her carpal
tunnel syndrome a little bit I think a
bored nervous about me a good sleep
what makes this routine surgery so
unusual is that the total price which
comes to two thousand seven hundred and
fifty dollars is posted online we
decided we would have price honesty
dr. Keith Smith is the anesthesiologist
on duty and the co-founder and managing
partner here at the surgery center of
Oklahoma which is located in Oklahoma
City
three years ago Smith and his partner
started listing their prices on the
surgery centers website a move that
would only be considered radical in the
health care industry it makes me mad
that a lot of people are bankrupted by
our current health care system when when
the costs are many times completely
unjustified let's say June with Scouse
Key been treated instead at a
traditional hospital nearby not only
with the hospital charge more than
double the surgery centers price since
she hasn't met her deductible which
Koski would have had to pay the lion's
share the bill herself at the surgery
center the bill was so low that her
employer simply covered it she paid
nothing I like to think of what is done
with all of the dollars that are not
spent on health care here that would
have been spent at one of the big
hospitals across town which Koski ended
up at the surgery center because she and
her employer were directly responsible
for paying the bill if an insurance
company was covering it she would have
had no compelling reason not to pick the
more expensive option the surgery center
is part of a growing phenomenon of
patients and companies breaking away
from the traditional health care
industry with its distorted incentives
and outrageous prices as Obamacare
drives out what's left of markets in
medicine Americans are increasingly
turning to providers like the surgery
center which show that it is possible to
offer high-quality health care at low
prices it's always been interesting to
me that in any other business tons of
research has done into making systems
more efficient but in medicine somehow
another that is just completely lost dr.
Jason Sigmund regularly performs
procedures at both the surgery center
and at Integris Baptist Medical Center
which is the epitome of a traditional
hospital
it's run by Integris health which is the
largest healthcare provider in Oklahoma
serving over 700,000 patients a year
sigmund says the surgery center is so
much
more efficient than Integris that it can
perform twice as many surgeries there in
a single day
we have pressures to do that because the
amount that we get reimbursed for the
same case that they do at the hospital
is such a fraction that were really
forced to be efficient the long-term
players in the medical business need to
be pushed to a new way of looking at
things dr. Stan Baker is chairman of the
ear nose and throat Department at
Integris Hospital like dr. Sigman he
prefers to do his procedures at the
surgery center of Oklahoma the place run
recognizing the needs and of busy
surgeons to devote their attention to
the important technical details not have
to worry about a lot of other things
that's that's what happens here except
for the clerical staff every employee at
the surgery center is directly involved
in patient care human resources and
building maintenance those are the
responsibilities of the head nurse one
of the main reasons our prices are so
low is that we don't have administrators
in three or four thousand dollar suits
running around and vice president's at
every imaginable level at Integris
health the top eighteen administrative
employees made on average four hundred
and thirteen thousand dollars in 2010
the wastefulness of traditional
hospitals is reflected in the way they
build for their services we obtained an
itemized bill for a procedure performed
that Integris Hospital called a complex
sinus surgery which treats chronically
infected sinuses the surgeon was dr.
Jason segment who also does the
procedure at the surgery center of
Oklahoma where the total price is five
thousand eight hundred and eighty-five
dollars the bill from Integris comes to
more than 33,000 dollars although the
actual bill was even higher than that
since unlike the surgery centers price
that doesn't cover the surgeon or
anesthesiologist Integris can get away
with charging more than six times the
surgery centers price because generally
its patients don't pay these bills so
there's no real sticker shock this leads
to outrageous markups such as a 360
dollar charge for asteroid called
dexamethasone which wholesale cost 75
cents or three charges totaling 630
dollars for a painkiller called fentanyl
citrate which cost the hospital a dollar
50 they're actually inclined to embrace
waste the more things that are opened up
or used at a hospital the bigger the
hospital bill becomes although hospitals
early collect the full amount printed on
the bill private insurance companies
generally pay around 60% of the total
which is still many times with the
surgery center charges Integris
justifies its giant bills on the grounds
that it loses a lot of money treating
patients that don't have any insurance
at all in a statement Integra said it is
our mission to treat every patient who
enters our facilities regardless of
their ability to pay and so our charges
must be set at a level to allow us to
recover costs you have turned mister
president the right of every American to
have access into decent health care into
reality for the first time in American
history
enter Obamacare which seeks to extend
insurance to all Americans so the
traditional hospitals can collect money
from all their patients the truth is
that this won't do anything to stop
exploding health care costs because when
the bill goes to the insurance companies
are the government it inevitably looks
like this only when patients are
responsible does the bill look like this
but companies are beginning to revolt
against the system that's eating away at
their profit margins it just didn't feel
right when you got a pacemaker bill come
in and the charge for that pacemaker was
a hundred thousand dollars it hasn't
always been a hundred thousand dollars
Jay Kempton runs a Healthcare
Administration firm in Oklahoma City it
works with companies that pay their
employees healthcare bills directly out
of their revenues well now as we've made
it a point to dig under the surface
we're seeing for instance that that
pacemaker may be nine thousand dollars
and the rest of that is Marquette he
came up with a simple way for his
clients to save money they waive all
co-pays if their employees agree to be
treated at the surgery center instead of
a traditional hospital shortly after
Ethan I started working together it
really kind of dominoed we've had four
different facilities in in our
marketplace have come to us and wanted
to be able to have transparent pricing
that was is for for cash paying
customers today the surgery center is
doing brisk business and Smith and his
partners are considering expanding now
the the jig is up and everyone can see
what the prices are here so it robs
individuals who had skimmed off of
healthcare dollars it robs them of their
excuse for making sure that patients go
to the more expensive places